Dave Rubin the nicest guy in politics
thank you for coming by great to have
you now it is time for my final thought
none of the people disrespecting the
national anthem and none of those
cheering them on has made a coherent
case for the protest which I suspect is
because the protesters incoherent make
no mistake the disrespect shown is
explicitly toward the national anthem
which is itself a symbol of the country
if these football players were to kneel
or turn their backs on a police officer
they're disrespected be toward the
police and the protests toward any
alleged police brutality if they were to
kneel or turn their backs at the site or
mention of President Trump their
disrespect would be toward President
Trump and the protests toward his
administration the symbol has relation
to the symbolized but they're kneeling
for the national anthem
and so the disrespect and protests are
pointed toward the country itself there
is an irony here we pay these grown men
tens of millions of dollars per year to
run around and entertain us these men
then turn around without any fear of
prosecution
and insult the country that has given
them more wealth equality and freedom
than any citizenry has ever enjoyed in
the history of the world that prosperity
equality and liberty are not the natural
state of things they are uniquely
American they rest on the foundation of
America to undercut that foundation is
to make impossible all that that
foundation secures to quote Chesterton
there is a thought that stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped
on that I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael nul show come back tomorrow
we'll do it all again
[Music]
you
[Music]